I'm in Basel in Switzerland the River
Rhine run through here and if you want
to get across it then there are four
ferries I mean there are bridges as well
but the ferries keep going is a tourist
attraction as a tradition and for some
folks an actual way to get where you
want to go also occasionally a fondue
restaurant because Switzerland but these
ferries have no paddles no oars no
engines nothing onboard to power them
put them out in the open ocean or on a
lake and they just drift and yet here
they move so here's how they work there
is a wire strung across the river and
the ferry is connected to it this little
thing called a traveler that goes back
and forth smoothly the ferry just have a
rudder for steering so when it's time to
cross the captain angles the boat
against the current and uses the force
of the river itself to push the boat
across without that cable it's a drift
downstream fast but since it can't it
just crosses the river instead no
gasoline no human effort just the force
of the river boats like this are called
reaction ferries and there are examples
all over the world sometimes the designs
a little different but the principle is
always the same I only learned about
them a few weeks ago and in hindsight
they seem incredibly obvious you have an
object that needs energy sitting on top
of a massive constant energy source just
waiting to be harnessed but if you'd ask
me how to connect those two things
before I knew the answer then my first
thought would probably have been some
over complicated over-engineered plan
like putting a water wheel on the side
of the river and then using that cable
to send power to an electric motor on
the boat I mean there's a hydroelectric
dam not far away I'd like to think that
have worked it out eventually but I
would probably miss the easy option to
start with - anyone who grew up in a
place with these ferries it's a really
obvious idea but to everyone else it's
an invention we've never thought of and
to be fair this is only a good solution
a few places you need a strong fast
steady river like the Rhine at a place
where it isn't tidal and where it isn't
particularly seasonal either but if I've
missed that then the obvious follow-up
question is well what else one list and
if there anything out there that every
single human has missed maybe there is
still some big obvious in hindsight
stuff out there that will change the
world
just as soon as someone thinks
it
you